what's going on everybody we have some
good news about Captain America and
Avengers for just a heads up I'm doing
another giveaway I'll be giving away a
few copies of Avengers infinity war
blu-ray all you have to do to enter the
contest is hit that subscribe button
with the notifications turned on and
comment below with your favorite
superhero that can be from any universe
you want so as you all may know Avengers
infinity war is out and one of the
really cool things that comes along with
that not only being able to watch the
movie as many times as you want
not only that but we get deleted scenes
and we get commentary the specific
commentary that I am talking about is
from Christopher Markus who co-wrote
Avengers infinity war and his commentary
reveals that Captain America is going to
have a much larger role in Avengers 4
than he did in Avengers infinity war oh
by the way this is a friend of mine tree
[Music]
which makes sense because I guess a lot
of people have counted and said that
Steve Rogers apparently only gets about
7 minutes of screen time and infinity
war but I mean when you have so many
heroes in one movie well what can you
really expect you can just all fast
okay so here's some of the commentary
from Christopher Markus we have a unique
opportunity here
there are certainly other movies that
have done it but we know we have two
movies to tell character arcs some
characters are going to be better served
in the second story I think it's okay to
say that cap has a big story in the
second one okay so he says that they
have a unique opportunity and that some
characters are going to be better served
in a second story I think it's pretty
obvious who these characters are seen as
how Thanos swiped away half of our
heroes but I think there's a little bit
of foreshadowing going on here where he
says cap as a big story you know it's
obvious everybody knows it by now it's
already been out there that out of all
the original Avengers that are left
Captain America and Iron Man are the
most likely to go or should I say Chris
Evans and Robert Downey jr. and whether
that is them retiring and passing down
their Mantle's of Captain America and
Iron Man or them dying they're going to
have huge roles in Avengers for not only
because they're the OGS of the Avengers
but they're probably on their way out
there are so many theories out there
regarding the deaths of Iron Man and
Captain America whether that is from
Steve Rogers sacrificing himself
fighting Thanos one-on-one so Ironman
can get away or Tony has to sacrifice
someone he loves in order to get the
soul stone and in doing so he sacrifices
Steve Rogers fares Captain America
picking up Thor's hammer to fight Thanos
right before he dies whatever it may be
they're all out there right now whatever
happens it's going to be super dramatic
and it's gonna be touching and no matter
what happens I freaking hope he yells
Avengers Assemble
because if they retire his character or
they kill him off without him saying
Avengers Assemble
we're all gonna lose it so whatever this
major huge role that he is going to have
in a vendor sport is I just hope that he
owes Avengers Assemble let me know in
the comments below what you think
Captain America's huge role is gonna be
in Avengers 4 and like I said we're
doing a giveaway giving away Avengers
infinity war blu-rays all you have to do
to enter
is like the video comment below with
your favorite superhero and make sure
you subscribe to my channel thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]